title 42 was not created by Trump but it
was used by Trump as an emergency
measure in the context of the pandemic
to more quickly turn around those
undocumented immigrants encountered by
immigrations enforcement agencies like
border patrol instead of a longer
process before they could be deported
and sent back to their country of origin
title 42 allowed to allowed it to be
done more quickly now I don't want to
focus on the obvious absurdity
of the very same Republicans who said
kovid's no big deal
on the other hand on the other side of
their mouth saying covet is such a big
deal that we need to enact an emergency
measure because it's so big a deal we
need to turn around undocumented
immigrants instead of giving them the
due process that they normally get let's
put that aside because that's beyond the
scope of this conversation